my god your hair you've dyed it uh
incredibly bright red
yes amazing yeah how do you how do you
like first of all what what caused that
uh decision
what didn't you what i mean if we're
gonna start at the beginning
yeah my whole life was leading here
you're a natural redhead all the way huh
yeah
that must be nice it's not it wasn't
nice when i was a kid i hated it yeah
well you know because kids would pick on
you
and uh um well there are other reasons
they would pick on me
uh that was really weird but uh
but yeah having red hair wasn't a cool
thing when i was a boy what year did you
get
tall well it was late it happened late i
was in my late 30s
uh seriously i was one of those kids
that grew
very quickly uh i would say halfway
through high school
i mean yeah like the incredible hulk
like my clothes split
and um so uh yeah i don't know why i
don't know why
yeah i uh you know my mother was a
redhead so i think that for me
she was always like the red monopoly
piece and i would be the yellow one
so it was hard for me to imagine ever
being not a yellow
right which is what i call it and uh
then
it really it just uh i did this new new
jab
new gig and uh you know boom i'm poison
ivy in the cramps so
that's what happened so you decided
you're going to go from a blonde to
redhead now do you feel any differently
about yourself as a redhead how do you
feel
do you people treat you differently
absolutely uh i think that
uh speaking of unpleasant high school
experiences uh
i mean i think that in in high school
maybe uh some of the the girls identify
but i think boys really like waves you
know what i mean i came up in a real
kate moss era
and so i was never quite uh a wife and
i i think that it was there was
something about being shy or something
but now as a redhead i feel like i can
really
uh own my space i feel like if i i walk
into the deli and i say give me a
packing as strong as cigarettes for
example
i'm really occupying myself and my body
better than ever
i don't understand why that's true as a
redhead that doesn't work for me at all
like you know no it's never i've never
felt like i could walk into a place and
be like hey everyone
red's in town give me the best gum you
got like no that's a
great great strong lineage for redheads
right i mean you have zzz top
pippy long stockings ginger baker
oh great one of the great drummers from
cream yeah
from wendy's hamburgers yes santa claus
before he went gray from that one tv
special there's one tv special where
he's a redhead that went white that's
the only one that's the only uh
documentary evidence
yes red sonja yeah bella lugosi
was a veteran now you're just saying
details
now you're just saying random
celebrities sylvester stallone
redhead casper the friendly ghost
red-headed boy who died
you're just saying [ __ ] now you're
welcome
don't make me scooby-doo redhead